je veux vous remercier
d'attirer notre attention à tous sur
l'autisme et les troubles de
neuro-développement et d'avoir parlé de
cette journée du 2 avril qui est la
journée mondiale de l'autisme alors oui
depuis 2018 la stratégie nationale a
déployé 550 millions d'euros qui ont été
de crédit nouveau qui ont été mises en
œuvre dans le cadre de cette stratégie
structurer la recherche d'abord vous
l'avez dit 5 centres d'excellence qui
ont été formés structurées un groupement
d'intérêts scientifiques ce qui fait que
la recherche nationale est à
l'avant-garde de la recherche européenne
aujourd'hui et je crois que ça peut être
une fierté pour nous deuxièmement bien
sûr repérer précocement les enfants
prendre en charge précocement au sein de
ces plateformes de coordination 97
plateformes qui ont été créés et 41
000 enfants pris en charge au sein de
ces plateformes depuis qu'elles ont été
constituées
c'est assez important pour être souligné
bien entendu les dispositifs
médico-sociaux qui ont été inclus dans
l'école que ce soit l'école maternelle
l'école primaire les collèges
440 dispositifs médico-sociaux afin
d'aider ses enfants à intégrer l'école
de la République et puis bien sûr
l'emploi accompagné parce que ces
personnes-là accès dans l'emploi
également et on les accompagne à pouvoir
rentrer dans les entreprises et accéder
à des emplois de qualité et puis nous
avons bien sûr mis en oeuvre des lieux
pour les autistes avec des troubles très
complexes des lieux de résidence afin de
les protéger et de faire en sorte de les
prendre en charge de façon efficace
alors nous allons poursuivre la
construction avec une nouvelle stratégie
nationale qui est aujourd'hui en
construction avec les associations avec
les personnes concernées comme
d'habitude dans le handicap tout se
construit avec Association et personnes